the second incident was uh with one of
my best friends he was getting a little
drunk we were in the pub
and he started saying Hell
he wasn't bothered about me and we were
having a political debate
and he wasn't bothered about me and even
on martial arts he could still beat me
and I just got off the bar stool stood
back a little bit and said
do you really want to end up with a
broken arm so you can't run your own
business because I knew he was
self-employed don't be so stupid calm
down
so that was
an odd experience when you get it
attacked by one of your best friends and
somebody who I done a lot of business
with
he was in carlsels and he used to sell
me cars and I bought them to sell at my
garage
so that was the second instant but I
knew that it was real and it wasn't just
one of those things
when these things are real it comes
instantly you don't have a lot of time
to get into big arguments
and build up well that's what I've found
these things usually
flower up really fast
I dealt with it and afterwards I thought
about it and I thought I was more
concerned for him because I don't know
if I would have been able to break his
arm or not if I was convinced I could
because of the angle he was sitting on
the bar stool he would like to lunged
out at me with his left arm
and
perhaps I would have not broken it who
knows but I'm just saying that
I talked him down
and you're as good as you are at the
time of it happening you can't prepare
for it I don't believe anybody can
prepare for I don't care what anybody
says in Aikido
unless you become a Buddhist monk and
control yourself to some
very high degree we are normal people
and adrenaline either runs
and disturbs us so we can't concentrate